ils vivent villes refuges endroit
sécuritaire qui se prépare au pire on y
trouve des centaines d'abris anti bombe
en plein centre-ville de la cité
historique l'air de je dissimule un
vaste réseau de tunnels construits il y
a près de 150 ans des affiches indiquent
les entrées de cet abri antibombes
récemment déblayer et restauré par des
citoyens bénévoles
les marches même directement à une
vieille et lourdes portes de métal puis
dans les tunnels en briques pas de
lignes droites l'abri datant de l'époque
austro-hongroise qu'on le vive
s'appelait lembergs est un vaste
labyrinthe avec quelques sorties de
secours la ville l'a même fait installer
des bancs pour ceux qui viendront se
réfugier tout a été pensé dans ses vieux
tunnel quand les sirènes d'alarmé de
raids aériens commence à sonner dans la
ville le courant électrique est établi
dans les tunnels donc il y à de la
lumière il ya même des prises
électriques si jamais les gens doivent
rester ici pendant longtemps donc on
peut charger certains appareils cet abri
antibombes antique n'est cependant pas
bien connue des nombreuses évacuer
ukrainien venus se réfugier à lviv
[Musique]
sous des les sirènes d'alarmé sont
partout où elles vivent les familles
demeurent calmes et viennent trouver
refuge dans les vieux tunnel
confusion personne ne sait trop où se
diriger il ne faut pas être
claustrophobe dans ces tunnels étroits
qui deviennent rapidement bruyant
cet abri va tenir le coup jusqu'à ce
qu'un missile dôme tout près 17
grand-mère arrivé de kiev avec ses
petits enfants elle loge tout près des
tunnels et vient souvent dans le parc
avec la famille
fausse alarme l'alertent prend fin après
seulement quelques minutes mais on ne
sait jamais ces tunnels serviront
peut-être davantage dans cette guerre
c'est la grande peur ici philippe
leblanc radio canada vivent en ukraine